نعود الى مساء العربيه وهذه الساعه
الاخباريه مره اخرى تثير الاستعانه في
الاعلانات في يوتيوبرز او المؤثرين تثير
الجدل ومره جديده هذه المره في الاردن
كثيرون اعترضوا على ظهور نجميه تيك توك في
الاردن محمد المقابله وزوجته التونسيه ضحى
في برنامج مسابقات جرى تصويره في متحف
الدبابات الملكي حاله الجدل اثيرت بعدما
اعتبر رواد منصات التواصل الاجتماعي ان
البرنامج اساء للقيمه الرمزيه للدبابات
واعترضوا على تحويل المتحف الى لوكيشن
تصوير لنجوم تيك توك بعد هذه الموجه ردت
اداره متحف الدبابات الملكي قائله ان
الانتقادات بها معلومات غير صحيحه كما ان
البرنامج يستهدف فئه الشباب لزياره المتحف
والتعرف على التاريخ وبطولات الجيش
الاردني
مابيع فريقي اوف صراحه ضحى اقنعتيني وعشان
هيك انا المسامحه كريم اليوم راح خليكي مع
فريقك
سؤال ضحى شو يعني كلمه سلطانه